this is a very interesting family to to
to to marry into it is interesting
because on you know on one level there
just a family right everybody sits
around and we play charades and it's
right fun and is that what you guys said
I know the candidates are doing are they
playing charades that's not what we
thought okay okay
very competitive game I I would imagine
they're competitive um so on one hand
you know you have that and then on the
other hand you know I don't know your
play Trivial Pursuit and it's like oh
your uncle you know and that's weird
right because it's like this yeah
worldwide
well it's like this legendary American
family that you're now a part of yeah